when you open your phone what social app
do you check first probably instagram it
used to be twitter when twitter was fun
pat i'm sure is a big tick tocker it
runs in the family what nfl jersey did
you save all your allowance for as a kid
that's a trick question i can't say it
we're gonna go with brett favre i saved
all my allowance money for a jerry rice
jersey because he was the man in san
francisco at the time what i would have
wanted was probably joe montana or jerry
rice dez bryant was the first one i ever
got when you were younger
what video game was your go to
definitely mlb the show either rbi
baseball 94 or
madden 94. i don't think tom's ever
played a video game no caveman didn't
have video games back then i just went
to wyoming or something like that
probably pretty bored out there you
probably played a lot of video games my
video game go to as a kid was definitely
madden what is the song you remember
most when driving in the car when you
got your life that's a good one who was
i rocking to young tyga maybe grenade
bruno mars tupac's greatest hits garth
brooks county crows 90s by far the best
time for music any idea what the number
one song on the billboard charts was in
2000 when you were drafted oh god 2 000
uh so what was the song it was a country
grammar country grammar nelly let's go
the actual answer was breathe by faith
hillary oh man i wouldn't have got that